[Music]
yeah we have on the show reviewed many
different types of tick tock videos
which
i'm sure you've noticed and are grateful
for but the one genre we haven't spent
much time on
is abortion tick tock it's mostly for my
own sanity and emotional health that
i've avoided
wading into these waters and yet i find
that i can no longer avoid it especially
as i so often see these videos posted on
twitter or facebook
by people who sincerely believe that
some sort of brilliant and unanswerable
argument
has been presented so for our daily
cancellation today we're going to play
some of these clips
and uh respond to them now there are
many abortion related videos on the
platform
where women simply brag about their own
abortions and pretend to think that it's
funny that they've just murdered their
own child
those are horrifying and sad and
infuriating and evil but
there isn't much else to say about them
and certainly no reason to play them
it's no mystery why a woman might react
that way to her abortion it's a
rationalization
it's a defense mechanism these are women
who've done a horrible thing and they
know they've done a horrible thing at
some level
they know it and now they're
overcompensating because people who are
happy about the decisions they make
don't have to make videos convincing
strangers that they're happy about their
decisions as a general rule
now it may be true that some of these
women have successfully deluded
themselves
but that only lasts so long the fact is
despite what lies the abortion industry
tells
abortion is not the undoing of a
pregnancy it's not
a reset or reverse button allowing you
to go back to being a happy carefree
childless person
in pregnancy you become a mother
in abortion you become the mother of a
dead child
so there's a loss there's an absence
and you will feel it eventually that's a
fact
so all of the the the videos you see i'm
so happy about it
um these are people who have deluded
themselves and that's all that is but
let's move on to the actual arguments
we're going to play a few videos here of
people on tik tok
presenting their best arguments for
abortion and let's start with this one
if a 16 year old wanted to adopt a child
the government wouldn't allow it she
isn't done with her education she isn't
financially
stable yet and she isn't a legal adult
but if she gets pregnant the government
can ban her from getting an abortion
how is that logical um
uh a few issues here first of all 16
year olds are not
banned from getting abortions so that's
the whole premise of this argument
is wrong um they're not 16 year olds
can get abortions unfortunately they can
get abortions though in some states they
need parental consent
in other states they don't need parental
consent at all they can just walk in and
get the abortion
so no need to worry ma'am your dreams
have come true teenage girls can kill
their babies
and are killing their babies so your
utopia is a reality congratulations
let's pretend that you're correct for a
moment let's pretend that 16 year olds
can't adopt which they can't and also
can't get abortions
and you think there's there's some kind
of conflict between these two
propositions you ask how this would be
logical well
let me tell you because the common
thread is one of mental competence
maturity
a 16 year old isn't mentally competent
enough to adopt she also isn't mentally
competent enough
to make the decision to take someone's
life
that's a bit of a misnomer because
nobody should be able to do that there's
no level of mental competence that
should permit you to kill a baby
even so abortion is a choice which has a
profound
impact on two lives at least
her own as the mother and the life of
her child which she is ending
i would call that a profound impact is a
16 year old
old enough to analyze those
ramifications and make a properly
informed choice
no but then if she doesn't have the
abortion she'll be a mother you say
you know so so what about that no you're
wrong
she's already a mother as we have
previously established she's a mother at
conception
the human has been conceived that's done
that part is over completed
fulfilled the question is what to do
about this child or with this child
you say she isn't old enough to care for
the child so what she's old enough to
kill it
i say that's insane and morally
grotesque and evil and also illogical
instead we could try to find someone who
can care for the child if she can't
and and and uh by the way we hear about
the bad the you know kids who are up for
adoption and they can't find anyone to
adopt them
and okay well it sounds so easy you put
the child up for adoption with a baby
for adoption
there's going to be in the system
forever and no one's going to adopt them
that's not true okay now it is true
sadly and tragically that um older kids
who end up in the system oftentimes it's
very difficult to find a family that
will take them in
that's a terrible thing that is not the
case for babies
there is a waiting list a million miles
long
of families waiting to adopt babies
so a 16 year old can't has a baby
can't care for the baby you put that
that child up for adoption
and he will be adopted by a loving
family
very quickly one other thought though
you don't think 16 year olds are old
enough to be parents okay
are they old enough to choose their
gender what do you think about that
i think i already know your answer let's
watch another and see if these
arguments get any better let's talk
about abortion and specifically
the heartbeat bill when someone gets in
an accident and they're considered brain
dead
no one considers it morally wrong to
pull that person's plug or in their life
because although that person has a
beating heart they aren't a conscious
being they have no brain activity
here's another example why do most
people not consider it morally wrong to
kill an insect
but do consider it morally wrong to kill
a cat or a dog they both have beating
hearts
the difference between the two is level
of consciousness
a dog is very aware of its existence and
creates relationships with the things
around them
whereas an insect just lives off of
instinct they aren't aware that they
exist they just do
the thing i'm really confused about is
why all of a sudden when it comes to
abortion
we allow a beating heart to signify life
when in all other aspects of our life
a beating heart doesn't mean anything
what matters is level of consciousness
and the fetus and the first trimester
does not have consciousness
uh i don't know where to begin here
she's built a tower of false assumptions
and baseless assertions all resting on a
false premise taped up with red herrings
and non-sequiturs
so let's run through some things very
quickly number one you have no idea how
much
consciousness a quote fetus possesses
number two you have no idea if a dog is
aware of its existence
i doubt that it is personally does does
a dog have
an eye concept is it aware of itself as
an
eye a self can a dog
think to itself and and and and can
think oh i am doing this
i am doing that i doubt it we could
debate that but nobody really knows
number three you say heartbeat doesn't
matter in any other area of life really
so it's all about consciousness so
you're arguing that it should be
considered morally permissible to kill
anything that is not conscious or that
we assume isn't conscious
okay then how would you feel if i went
and chopped down 100 trees for no reason
let's start with that what if i captured
a thousand eagles and shot them all
and threw their bodies in a dumpster how
would you how would that rub you
are eagles more conscious than unborn
children i don't think so
four if consciousness is the measure of
worth then what about levels of
consciousness among and within
born humans consciousness is not
one set thing there are degrees of it
a one-year-old is conscious but
certainly is
less aware than a ten-year-old does a
ten-year-old then possess more moral
worth what about a 30 year old as
compared to an 85 year old dementia
patient
so you've created this scale of worth
this way of measuring things
and i don't think you've thought about
where it leads or maybe you have which
is even worse
number five here's a big one important
point even if i agreed with your whole
premise and all of your assertions which
i don't
you've got a major problem the unborn
child unlike the brain dead person or
the insect
is only in this limited conscious state
temporarily
we know that he will soon have more
consciousness he is headed towards that
point with every passing second
inevitably if you leave him to his own
devices
so what if we knew take the brain dead
person
what if we knew that person would wake
up in three weeks
still okay to kill them so that's the
real analogy here
a person with limited mental functioning
who we know for a fact
will soon have full mental functioning
in any other context would you say that
it's okay to exploit that limited window
of reduced consciousness
and kill the person but he's not
conscious right now let's kill him
but that's bad news for anyone who's
ever i don't know gone to sleep
let's try one more video do
conservatives realize
that by banning abortion their taxes are
going to go up
by a lot rich women will always have
access to abortion no matter what the
law is they will always be able to get
it
so forcing poor women to have children
that they cannot afford
even in the cases of rape and incest
means the state has to pay for it
meaning your tax dollars
romania's welfare system completely
collapsed when they banned abortion in
the 70s
and at that time their population was
about 20 million
texas has a population of 29 million
wow mic drop mind blown
taxes will go up do i realize that taxes
will go up if abortion is man here's a
better question
um do i give a damn see i i'm not sure
if your assumptions are actually true or
not the taxes will go up but
but if they are who cares do you realize
that the whole point of the pro-life
cause the whole argument we're making is
that human life has objective and
inherent value
our point is that a human's value is not
contingent on how convenient that life
is to those around it
if we believe that we'd be pro-abortion
like you but we don't so we're not
so if taxes go up because abortion is
banned okay
i don't like paying taxes but i'm not
going to support mass slaughter and
genocide just to avoid it
i mean we could also reduce our taxes by
just killing everybody on welfare right
now
how does that strike you see i'm not a
murderous sociopath who reduces human
life down to a matter of mere dollars
and cents
that's not my gig that's not my stance
it's yours remember so speak for
yourself or better yet
stop speaking because you and the rest
of abortion tick tock
are today absolutely cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date
on all of our future content